deutsche Soldaten der Bundeswehr im
Einsatz gegen Waffenschmuggler vor der
libyschen Küste in Mittelmeer
unterwegs im Rahmen der Mission Irini
[Musik]
frühmorgens gehen die beiden
schiffsversorgungsoffiziere Kapitän
Leutnant Philipp und Kathleen
Oberleutnant zu See vom
Einsatzgruppenversorger Bonn in Messina
Sizilien an Land heute werden die
Proviant und Materiallieferungen für den
weiteren Einsatz Richtung Libyen
erwartet
überall jetzt helfen der Hände die
Mannschaft ist damit beschäftigt die
wahre schnell zu sortieren und aus der
zunehmenden Hitze an Bord zu bringen
[Musik]
und Philipp müssten jetzt akribisch
aufpassen dass auch jede Bestellung am
Pier eingetroffen ist bis zu 100 Tonnen
an Material und Proviant können in den
Lagerräumen des einsatzgruppenversorgers
verstaut werden schließlich wird alles
in die Kühlung gebracht
rein so vom tiefkühlprogramm können wir
schon so bis zu sieben acht neun Monate
uns von ernähren dann gibt Kommandant
Eike Deussen das Zeichen zum Ablegen ins
Einsatzgebiet der Mission Irini Richtung
liby die Schlepper ziehen die Bonn aus
dem Hafen
doch plötzlich auf der Brücke Hektik
Schrecksekunden für die Mannschaft
der Schlepper vorne kollidiert frontal
mit dem mehr als 20.000 Tonnen schweren
mächtigen Kriegsschiff und hängt weiter
fest am Schleppseil das kann jeden
Moment reißen die Soldaten bringen sich
schnell in Sicherheit um nicht verletzt
zu werden
um die Schleppleine zu lösen müssen sie
massives Werkzeug verwenden
geschafft
beim Ablegen
ins Schiff gefahren interessanterweise
der gleiche Schlepper der uns beim
Anlegen auch schon eine dosiert hat
angerempelt oder wie auch immer ja ist
uns vor dem Buch Gefahren für die Bonn
kein Problem die Mission Irini weiter
fortzusetzen Richtung Libyen Irini das
griechische Wort bedeutet Frieden die
wichtigste Aufgabe dieses eu-manats für
die Bundeswehr das Waffen Embargo der
Vereinten Nation gegen Libyen
durchzusetzen
kurze Zeit später macht sich ein
litauisches boarding-team dass die
deutschen Soldaten unterstützt fertig da
sich ein Handelsschiff Richtung Libyen
in der Nähe befindet
geht natürlich um das Waffen in Baro
gegenüber Libyen das heißt man weiß dann
die die bestimmten Routen die Schiffe
die aus Türkei beispielsweise kommen und
nach Libyen geht die sind dann halt
vielleicht ein bisschen näher zu
betrachten mit schnellboden nähern sich
die Soldaten der Bundeswehr einem
handelsschiffenheit der libyschen Küste
abseits der gängigen flüchtlingsrouten
im Mittelmeer dieser bordkontakt neuen
sogenannter friendly approach ein
freundlicher Besuch im Austausch von
Informationen Überladung und Mannschaft
und nur mit Erlaubnis des Kapitäns
dieses Handelsschiffes
zeigt er uns das Wasser von sich gibt
dass es für uns in Ordnung es ist
eigentlich ein lockeres Gespräch sollte
seine freundlichen Atmosphäre doch auch
bei verdächtigen Schiffen kann die
hochmotivierte Mannschaft der Mann nicht
einfach so an Bord gehen und ein
Boarding eine gründliche Durchsuchung
durchführen strenge Vorschriften
innerhalb der Operation Irini sind
einzuhalten wie die Zustimmung des
flaggensstaates
der Flaggen starte wenn wenn der
Besitzer sagt gibt es nicht dann dürfen
wir ja nicht an Bord kommen in unserem
Fall haben wir jetzt in diesem Einsatz
noch keinen kein Boarding durchgeführt
wir haben halt das die Freddy projes
durchgeführt und haben so ein Lagebild
letztendlich für das Operation aufgebaut
das ist so das Ziel was wir haben wir
haben über an die 400 Schiffe inzwischen
abgefragt das haben wir gut gemacht das
heißt nicht nur weil wir kein Boarding
durchgeführt haben dass sie Operation
damit nicht erfolgreich ist die Bonn
fährt in einem Sicherheitsabstand
während des friends immer parallel zum
Handelsschiff
auf der Brücke wird der Einsatz der
Soldaten akribisch verfolgt alles genau
außens beobachtet das boarding-team
kommt zurück vom friendly approach auf
dem handelschiff doch bevor die Männer
an Bord kommen dürfen müssen sie ihre
Kleidung und Hände desinfizieren
unmögliche Krankheitserreger vom Schiff
fernzuhalten
Lagebesprechung mit Kommandant Deussen
nach dem Einsatz auf dem Handelsschiff
mit allen Beteiligten
ist der größte der drei
Einsatzgruppenversorger der deutschen
Marine
angetrieben von Dieselmotoren mit 20.000
PS kann das Schiff fast 21 Knoten
erreichen
das sind nach nur vier V8 Dieselmotoren
diese können pro Generator
872 Kilowatt erzeugen die Speisen alle
das gleiche Netz ein also 44 Volt 60
Hertz das ist im Vergleich wir können
also wir können keine Großstadt
versorgen damit also ist auf jeden Fall
sehr sehr viel Power die wir da erzeugen
können
Spezialisierungen sind hier gefragt um
den Antrieb und die komplizierte Technik
in Gang zu halten die Personaldecke für
diese Jobs bleibt dünn bei der
Bundeswehr
wir haben sehr viel Mangel
ist ja nicht mal uns auf dem Schiff das
ist generell auf fast allen Einheiten so
da muss man sagen es ist nicht für jeden
Mann die Seefahrt und auch noch als
Techniker hier man Arbeit 24/7 an Bord
man muss Wache stehen man muss natürlich
wissen was man macht
es ist äh sehr schwer nach und zu
gewinnen
auf dem Weg in die Küche
na alles gut bei euch
was macht ihr schönes
ich bereite gerade Nudelwasser vor wir
machen heute Nudeln mit Geschnetzeltes
wir kochen jetzt gerade zur Zeit für
knapp 200 Mann und ja das variiert aber
haben zwar Hafen oder
je nach Einsatzgebiet wo wir gerade sind
also das ist eigentlich nicht so
festgeschrieben
Hochbetrieb in der Küche
drei Monate lang ist Julian von seiner
Familie getrennt für seine beiden Kinder
hat er sich deshalb etwas Besonderes
einfallen lassen
ich bau jedes Mal wenn ich zur See
fahren Kalender für die Kinder und wenn
wir jetzt da so wie und jetzt ist etwas
kürzer aber man große Einsatz haben mit
180 Tagen Abwesenheit dann baue ich für
jedes Kind für jeden Tag ein Türchen das
ist wirklich jeden Tag was zum Essen hat
bis Papa wieder da ist 11:30 Uhr ist
Mittagszeit jetzt muss alles schnell
gehen tellerausgabe im Akkord 200 Mann
Besatzung kommen zum Essen
die Ankunft eines italienischen
boarding-teams wird auf dem flugdeckt
der Ernstfall wird mit den europäischen
Partnern innerhalb der Mission Irini
geübt
wir üben das ganze damit wenn wir in der
Mission an sogenannten friendly approach
oder auch tatsächlich ein Boarding
durchführen damit wir dann unsere
Spezialkräfte die dafür zuständig sind
auf die andere Einheit mit dem
Helikopter verbringen können beim
Boarding kann das ganze mit einem
Hubschrauber oder einem Boot stattfinden
oder beides gleichzeitig da kommt der
Helikopter
oder beides gleichzeitig und die
Italiener haben angemeldet dass sie das
bei uns einmal gerne üben würden und das
führen wir heute durch
das Abseilen muss ständig trainiert
werden
nach wenigen Augenblicken ist alles
vorbei der Helikopter bringt das
italienische boarding-team wieder zurück
auf die Fregatte Libeccio die die
Mission Irini begleitet kurze Zeit
später fährt sie parallel zur Bonn weil
sie dringend Kraftstoff braucht
als allererst sind wir wirklich dafür da
um andere Schiffe mit allem was Sie
brauchen zu versorgen wir haben das in
erster Linie Kraftstoff weil das ist das
in der Regel was auf anderen Schiff auf
kleineren Schiffen auf Fregatten zuerst
ausgeht und wir können auch Proviant sei
es nun kühl tiefgekühlt oder auch ganz
normaler trockenproviant an andere
Schiffe übergeben also vom Grundsatz her
alles was Sie brauchen Salz und die Cola
Dose ja oder der Karton Papier weil das
Druckerpapier ausgeht
[Musik]
täglich wird er Ernstfall geprobt um als
Versorger im Kampf bei Evakuierungen
oder seenotrettungen vorbereitet zu sein
die Bonn verfügt über eine eigene
lazarettstation kann mehr als 100 leicht
verletzte im Einsatz versorgen
Schichtdienste rund um die Uhr an Bord
der Bonn die ganze Nacht hindurchbetrieb
in der Backstube zwei Bäcker Backen
täglich 300 Brötchen einige Kuchen und
Torten und bis zu 20 Brote
ein 24-Stunden-Einsatz der Bundeswehr in
der Mission Irini
am nächsten Vormittag liegt die Bonn in
Augusta Sizilien an direkt am Pier
gegenüber ein amerikanisches
Kriegsschiff für Kathleen die letzte
Möglichkeit noch einmal zum Sightseeing
von Bord zu gehen denn der
Einsatzgruppenversorger kennt
anschließend nach drei Monaten wieder
nach Wilhelmshaven zurück ein See
Fernaufklärer ein Flugzeug wird dann die
Mission Irini weiter unterstützen